we are playing menger mania 1962. now
i'm going to play the opening that i
have been playing
against 1d4 which is the king's indian
defense
those of you just joining describe i
will explain
once again the main sort of ideas of
this opening
if you've never played the king's indian
it can look terrible what am i doing i'm
giving him
full control of the center and that's
the point of the king's indian what you
do is you give your opponent control of
the center
with the ultimate aim of attacking that
center with your pieces from a distance
[Music]
it's called a hyper modern opening so
here's the thing
i'm going to go e5 and here we have it
right attacking his center
with my pawns this is the main move it
does not blunder upon
uh and i'll explain everything after the
game it's up string
good to see you and we're gonna open up
the center so that we can more easily
attack the e4 pawn with our pieces
how should i attack the e4 pawn
did somebody tell me the simple way
bingo rookie 8
he's got f3 what is this move done
immediately remember what i told you
last game whenever the f pawn is pushed
you need to understand the drawbacks of
every move that your opponent plays
now this is just a general weakening
move but look at this bishop on e3
this bishop is undefended what does that
mean
that means that if we can get this pawn
out of e4
that's going to be something a sticky
situation now we can't go d5
immediately right because he takes with
this one but can we prepare the move d5
can we prepare the pawn break d5 hoping
to exploit his
this is theory by the way he's he hasn't
done anything wrong this is the main
line
but if white doesn't know exactly how to
play here he can get in very big trouble
he plays it correctly with queen d2
we've got d5
anyway because even though the bishop is
defended
it's still very flimsy all right this
goes back to the concept of
okay so e5 just gives up a pawn that's
definitely not the best way to play it
and
uh we've gotten everything we've opened
up the e file which we wanted and we've
won a pawn
okay so now let's continue our
development by playing knight to c6 if
he takes my knight
we take with the pawn and then we are
able to support
the pawn on d5 queen e8 was possible but
then he could have just dropped his
bishop back right we don't want to like
put all of our aces on the table
at once so
okay what should we do who can this is
an interesting situation
there's many ways to play it but um i
want you guys to sort of
be be engaged here in the in the
development now rook takes e3
is interesting but it doesn't work and i
will i will show this
after the game so
in if we were to follow the rules by the
book
we would say okay the bishop is not
developed we need to develop the bishop
where should we develop it i don't like
bishop f5 because it allows knight takes
f5
so we're just going to go bishop d7
remember what i always say
not every one of your pieces needs to be
working on you know
the coveted vaccine distribution you
could have a piece that's just sort of
chilling you know on a beach somewhere
and that's the bishop okay
the point of playing bishop d7 is to
just develop it connect the rooks
uh and and and you're fine okay
so what should we do now well i'm
looking at the knight
and that's setting the metal detector
off of my head whoa wait a second
knight's defended by the queen but
there's a bishop here i can take on d4 i
can get his queen onto a very vulnerable
square
why is it vulnerable because it's
x-rayed by the bishop this is called an
x-ray
and the x-ray is a precursor to a
discovered attack or a discovered check
where you move you basically you tear
the cover off
and then that bishop is going to attack
the queen but we want to get the most
bang for our buck and as you guys are
indicating
knight h5 is the way to do it making
contact with the bishop
and now comes the winning idea
once he takes what should black now do
look at the position carefully how has
it transformed
what can we do to win the game that's
why i love the king's indian
you know white white makes one move
incorrectly and he loses the game we
chop off the defender
of the bishop on e2 type one and type
two undefended pieces come into play
i will recap that concept for you after
the game and we are gonna be up a full
piece
okay so i'm just making some notes about
what i want to talk about
it's very hard for me to sort of set in
an adequate manner introduce the king's
indian because it's such a complex
opening let's unpin ourselves
but i'll do my best and i've already
talked about it on some occasions
okay so uh he wants to go h5 some
shenanigans
let's let's cut that let's snip that in
the butt uh not necessary but still now
he's created a weakness on h4
queen is tied down to the pawn okay
let's not forget that he threatens uh
rook takes d7
where should our bishop go what would be
a nice active
solid square for the bishop not bishop
b5 because that would blunder it
but bishop to c6 right why is this a
good square because it's defended by a
pawn
that's the only way to make sure your
piece is really safe is when it's
defended by fun i will delve into that
after the game
and once again a huge shout out still we
have six thousand viewers
amazing stuff thank you guys so very
much
for all the support all the hype and and
the engagement everybody's engaged and
i love to see that so now we have this
rook on a it feels sad
sad it's left out um let's make sure
it's not left out by
by creating the alakine gun alakine's
gun
is essentially when you triple your
pieces i think technically it means like
queen behind the rooks
but informally it refers to any kind of
tripling along a file
named after alexander alekhine early
world
champion um fourth fourth world champion
from russia and now
if we remember something about his move
h4
right it created a weakness we always
need to sort of like a librarian we need
to
catalog all of our opponent's weaknesses
what should we do
check now let me
all right guys i'm gonna rub it in a
little bit
we can okay he resigned i was gonna rub
it in we could have gone rookie one with
the checkmate or queen f2
but we had a pretty checkmate by
sacrificing the rook we could have
stacked the rook to open his king up
further
and guess what rookie 2 is a simple mate
but if we wanted to rub it in even
further
who can tell me a very pretty follow-up
that we could uh
put on the board here
further ripping open his king position
queen g4 is possible yeah
but also bishop f3 sacrificing the
bishop check
rook cuts off the king has to go back
and now the ladder mate rookie two
queen g2 okay so there was an abundance
of mates here and he graciously resigned
all right so king's indian
first played in the in the year 1850 did
not become popular until the 1920s 1930s
and still rarely played until the 60s
and 70s
why because if you think about chess
history i've explained this before
when chess was first starting to be a
thing
uh people followed the rules right
people follow the rules and the rules
said that you had to control the center
and in the king's indian black most
certainly does not control the center
with his pawns
he controls it with his pieces that's
why the king's indian
is called a hyper modern opening because
in the 1920s
there was a group of uh pretty
interesting people
they were from all parts of europe and
they were called the hyper modernists
hyper modernist says guys let's let's
all chill out
let's uh you know sip on some wine and
the people from california said let's
you know
let's uh you know do something other
than sipping on wine
uh let's all chill out for a second
let's understand something
you don't always have to control the
center with pawns in order for your
development to be effective what they
said
is that let's let our opponents control
the center with his pawns
and then let's shoot these pawns down
from a distance that's why they deploy
the bishop here
and and that's why black sort of holds
back white center
without actually immediately contesting
it and only black puts pressure on that
center when he is ready to do so
that's sort of the philosophy of the
king's indian
and the movie five comes right
immediately striking
the pawn on d4 i've played the kings in
my whole life
um now why doesn't this blunder upon
why can't white just take the pawn
there's a small tactic here
uh and without this tactic the king's
indian would simply fail
yeah and i take c4 exposing the attack
on the knight equalizing the material
and white's gonna have
black's gonna have a massive bishop here
on e5
all right now commonly in the king's
indian white pushes d5 this creates a
locked center and then white castle's
king's side
this is what makes the king's indian
fascinating it's an attack on either
side of the
white attacks on the queen side black
attacks on the king side black goes for
checkmate
so it's a very ambitious opening it's an
opening for aggressive players it's a
very hard opening to learn
instead he decided to keep the center
open i opened it up
and uh queen d2 was played now using
chess base which i've
as i told you guys i have used it to
show you
these these these games
i am going to check for a second to see
whether this has ever actually happened
in tournament play
and one thing that you can check using
chess space which has the largest
uh database of official tournament games
ever assembled millions and millions of
them
i can check this position to see who's
played like this before
so queen to d2 100 okay over
over 500 games uh and gary kasparov had
a game here with the black pieces d5 is
the main move
and c takes d5 is rare only 22 games
and then the move e5 was only played
once in 2004
rook takes e5 so this position only
occurred once in recorded tournament
play in 2004
uh and of course i'm just much better
because i'm up
i'm up a pawn and i develop my knight in
that game
black played rook takes c3 which i
completely don't get i think it's
premature to do this even though
black actually won the game icelandic
player bjornsson
uh i think he went like this maybe
trying to pin anyways
development bishop to d7 um
now type one and type two undefended
pieces very quickly
um there's three types pieces can be
categorized broadly speaking into three
departments number one
undefended type one i i formulated this
myself it's a little clunky
but mark my words i think it's helpful
type one
undefended piece is a piece that is
literally unprotected
by any other pieces or pawns
does either side have any type 1
undefended pieces and the king we
exclude from this category and the queen
is in a special category
i'll explain that um in a moment
no he does not right then
type 2 undefended piece and a type 2
undefended piece
is a piece that is only defended by one
other piece
not a pawn not a game not a game
practice
one other piece which type 2 undefended
piece
jumps to mind using that definition
who can tell me the key of course the
bishop
now the third category is a defended
piece and in my definition
black technically has a type 2 on on g7
right i sound like a dentist
now is the g7 bishop vulnerable no
because white has no pieces there
okay so this is all only important if
it's relevant
now a defended piece is a piece that is
protected by a pawn or by
more than one piece okay this knight is
defended
this bishop is defended okay now again
this is just something i created to
facilitate
making the right observations now
here's the thing when this position is
reached how does my
how does my brain process
the position that's on the board well
there's a couple of things i notice the
first
is you guys all see this right the x-ray
but
then and this is the key bishop on e2
what kind of a bishop is it
using our categorization is it defended
it's a type addicting heir thank you for
the prime it's a type 2. how about the
bishop on a4
what can you tell me about this bishop
it's a type 2 now the queen
i told you i'd talk about that later the
queen is always undefended no matter how
many pawns or pieces are in
contact with it the reason the queen is
always undefended is because
when the queen is attacked by any piece
other than another queen it must move
does that make sense so you can have 50
pieces
quote-unquote defending it but it's
still going to have to move because it's
the most valuable piece
so there's three undefended pieces in
sort of the same zip code that's why i
see knight h5
and this bishop type 2 undefended only
the knight is defending it we chop the
legs off
and we win the bishop that's sort of the
logic hopefully that makes sense and the
rest is very straightforward
okay um that's i don't know about that
luke but you can go pretty far i think
uh does queen before for him there
defend i don't think it does
i think he's pretty much busted uh queen
before is the same exact thing we take
the knight
sorry we take the bishop or we could
have also taken the knight first and
then take the knight
um so honestly i think this is an
underestimated way of thinking about
certain positions
you can do a lot by simply
constantly harping on the type one and
type two undefended pieces in a position
and if you guys just give me one moment
please let me see if i can find a very
quick
illustrative game from my own chess
career
like can you actually you know prac do
you actually practice what you preach
daniel you might be asking and
i try to when possible let me see if i
can oh
let me see if i can find a game from
early in my chess career
where i did something like that ah yes i
can actually i remember a nice little
combination i had which sort of exploits
this concept
2005 november 5th four days before my
10th birthday
this position appears on the board i'm
playing a 1400 yes i was 1800 once
bishop takes f3 so it looks like
everything is fine for white right i
mean material is equal
we can trade bishops but what does that
really do
right but here's the thing what can you
guys tell me about this bishop what kind
of a piece
is it
it's a type 2 undefended piece only the
rook is defending which means it's
incredibly vulnerable to tactics
and the move is rook to d1 distracting
the rook
from f1 it's got to take my opponent
resigned
because now i pick up the bishop and
simultaneously fork the rook so there's
another tactical idea that's involved
here
but you spot this by initially
understanding that the bishop on f3
is incredibly vulnerable as is the rook
on f1 this is the type 1 undefended
piece
so both are exploited here if only
white's king was let's say on g2
none of this would have worked that's
how important this difference is to make
why does bishop d3 not work for white in
a situation oh so
any questions by the way about this game
so type 1
is a piece that's not defended by any
pieces type 2 is a piece that is
defended by only one other piece and not
a pawn
uh mycon asks when you move bishop c6
why couldn't you activate the rook by
going rook to t8
a fantastic question so
and i'm actually sorry i'm not sure
where oh because the reason is because
this would have self-pinned me right and
now i can't move the bishop away
because the rook on date is going to be
hanging you got to be careful about that
he could even put pressure on the bishop
and i might even lose this bishop
black has ways to get out of this but
that's basically the reason right
why did 94 not work in that position
another great question
thank you for uh being brave 94 did
work kind of but he could have dropped
his queen back to d3
and the problem is even though the
bishop 2 is a type 2 undefended piece
there's no other undefended piece to
exploit
the two bishops are not forkable what's
wrong with e5 instead of knight f6
well the movie e5 here is the england
gambit that's not a great opening
but it's possible why are pieces covered
by a pawn
automatically defended in another
fantastic question that's the the last
question that will move on
um so here's the logic right
here is the logic um and once again
let's take a skeleton position on chess
space
okay so essentially yes there are no
kings on the board i'm just trying to
illustrate a concept here okay
so basically now my ocd is coming in i
gotta
gotta make sure the board is perfect now
i gotta make sure my webcam is flush
with the board because i can't look at
this
yeah it's gotta be perfect
even though this is gonna take me about
two seconds to show there we go
you guys you guys know what i mean right
i mean
perfect okay um
here's the thing um you see that the
bishops are in a standoff right bishops
are gonna stand up now let's consider
two distinct situations number one
let's move black's pawn out to b7 okay
does black's bishop and let's let's say
that white spawn is on g2
does either bishop have to move like is
either bishop actually threatened here
yes or no
no no because the pawns are defending
each pawn their respective bishop now
let's consider a different scenario
let's consider a scenario where instead
of that pawn on b7
black had a knight on d8 guarding the
bishop
panda panic thank you for panic thank
you for the prime what can white now try
to do
in order to remove the defender can you
guys give me
both moves that accomplish this task
bishop b6 is one of them bishop g5 is
the other
exactly and the other ones
just kidding i can this is a cool
feature in the new chess space i can
make illegal moves and i can even take
my own pieces
but anyways uh that's sort of the bottom
line now if we compare these two
situations right
do you guys see how much harder it is to
undermine a
pawn than to attack a piece that's the
bottom line you can't undermine this
point if you had a pawn on a5
you could have done this potentially but
this is very hard to orchestrate
that is why uh that is why i think that
you know pawns protecting a piece are
the safest
form of defense so that's why we call
them defended
okay so
let's play something different okay
let's play a modern
uh modern is the move g so that's like a
king's indian against e4
it's an opening that i have played for
many years now this is different than a
king's indian in the king's indian
white goes c4 so i can transpose the
game into the king's indian
but you should be careful about assuming
that this is the same thing this opening
is quite a bit more dubious
than the king's indian but it's still a
very reputable opening you know it's not
it's not been refuted
once again if you guys are paying
attention to my explanation of hyper
modern openings this is a
literally called the modern because look
at what we're allowing white to do we're
allowing white
to build massive control of the center
what we're going to do in return after
developing our pieces is attack that
center from a distance thank you cloud
nine point
so now we're gonna castle we're going to
develop
and white has several ways yep so he
plays the annoying move we're going to
take the pawn
and our fundamental strategy here is
going to be
to somehow find a way to undermine this
pawn chain but first our knight is
hanging
where should we put this knight so that
it remains active
knight d7 97 is a little bit passive
although that might be the theoretical
move
but knight h5 knights on the rim are
grim 98 is passive
knight g4 allows him to chase that
knight to the rim
with h3 knight d5 is the move don't
disqualify a move just because it leads
to a trade
trades can be good in fact this one is
he goes bishop c4 that's a good move
and now a very instructive moment should
we or should we not
take on c3 what do you guys say
well i'm going to tell you this we
shouldn't we shouldn't because
even though he uh has doubled pawns and
i'll explain this in greater depth after
the game
what happens as a consequence is that
the pawn on c3
lends support to the pawn on d4 that
creates a pawn chain so we're basically
helping
him uh buttress the pawn so instead
we're going to go bishop to e6
developing the bishop
and defending the knight we're going to
keep the blockade on d5 going strong
okay so knight take c3 is only a move
that we're going to make if we get
desperate if we have to take on c3
but remember people sometimes get
obsessed with doubled pawns
the way to think about double pawn they
can be actually good he just made a big
mistake
what did he just allow he miscalculated
he's gonna lose two pawns in the end
we'll look at the bishop
type one undefended type one undefended
piece there's a standoff
boom goes the dynamite that's a
discovered attack now he saw this
he saw this knight takes c6 that's his
idea
and the thing is if we take his knight
that's out of the question he takes ours
but of course we take the queen he takes
our queen
we take his knight what he didn't see
was that d4 is now hanging we have
succeeded in our strategy we have
literally
we have won both of his central pawns
that's the ideal scenario we are going
to be up
two puns in the end game okay so he
tries to trick us here
um that's actually not a bad move at all
that's quite an interesting move i
should say
let me calculate for a second guys let
me actually think before i make any
recommendations
because there's several things that we
can consider doing here
okay we're fine so what should we do
what we should do
is number one we should ask ourselves
can we defend the knight
can we defend the knight we can roof
takes d4 now the reason i was hesitant
here i'm not trying to flex the name
i was genuinely trying to calculate this
out
is because of this nasty little check
right our king is
a little bit in trouble here even
without the queens i had to make sure
that there were no shenanigans
in relation to the in relation to the to
the king so he goes c3 to chase away the
rook
oh but he found a really nice idea which
i actually miss he's going to go bishop
b3
that is actually brilliant by him he's
opening up a little window to the night
he's going to win back the night that's
not a problem though the reason oh he
doesn't do it
he should have done that he would have
still been in very big trouble had that
happened what does he allow us to now to
do
and this i calculated this i saw this is
what i had
actually expected we can take b2 that
knight is a very slippery piece
he does take c7 but it's not a problem
we move a rook to c8
i know it looks scary but remember we
are up a piece
the queens are off the board and look at
this trooper here on g7 it's covering
everything up it's making everything
safe
and he's gonna run out of gas it's just
crucial that we develop very fast
right we don't want to dilly dally any
longer we want to make sure that we get
our pieces out
super super fast and i really mean it in
fact
what move can we now make do not
automatically assume that you have to
move the knight
what can we do knight d3 is possible
but in the interest of rapid development
we can simply go knight to c6
undefended pieces type one knight c6
trades are in our favor we've linked up
the rooks we can take a deep breath
we're chilling we're living we're
grooving
and now we can remove remove our knight
from
b2 and go after the c5 pawn he can push
that pawn to e6
but that's why we deployed our knight to
c6 it's not going any further than that
okay well he's taken b7 which is
possible but now we can
chop the legs off of that pawn and all
we need to do now is be a little bit
careful because he's got some pinning
ideas and some action here
what should we do to you know reduce
some of the
you know turn the volume the volume dial
down a little bit on the heat we should
go rook b8 and chase after this rook
now then i didn't mean a premium of that
the knights defend each other
which is an ideal scenario but we also
need to be careful if he had a pawn on
f2
right if he had a pawn on f2 he would
have gone f4
and then we would have been uh
in trouble so let's take the rook here
we can just keep the knights like this
because
they're unassailable he's not actually
threatening anything right
so that makes sense to you guys he's not
actually threatening to take either
one of the knights because they're
completely self-sufficient so we can
infiltrate to the second rank
and he resigns great game okay
so what happened the modern g6 fiance
the bishop now the first time that the
modern was actually played
and again i love to give you guys these
multiple choice questions
uh historical now in recorded history
do you guys think that the modern was
played
in for the first time in it i'm going to
give you a multiple choice 1700
1800 approximately 1850
1900 or 1950
1700 increments of 50 17 1750
18 1850 19 1950.
it's called the modern okay a lot of you
guys are hitting it right on the money
i'm seeing the right answer more often
than not
the modern was first played by a guy
named pierre
charles sentiment he was one of the
strongest players
of the 19th century was first played in
london in 1842
by sandman against john cochran and he
didn't play it quite in the way that we
do now it was then played in 1852
1880 and by the early 1900s
by the by the second half of the 20th
century it had become very commonplace
so you could have counted on one hand
the amount of times basically that it
was played before 1950
those were some brave souls so santa
mancapo blanca played it a lot of
interesting people played it
i've played it many times myself now
he played what's called the austrian
attack why is it called the austrian
attack i don't actually
know um i guess maybe it was first
played in austria let's do some
investigating
this this move f4 was first played in
1951
in switzerland so not quite in austria
it was first played in the in in
switzerland by a very good player
joseph copper and i think he might have
been austrian
no he was swiss i don't know
maybe that's the austrian swiss attack
is what it should have maybe been called
but uh openings are not always named
after the first person who played them
this will be on the test anyways e5
pushing is pawn
we take it blockade on d5
i hope it made sense my explanation why
we didn't put the knight anywhere else
and now why not knight takes c3 people
consistently
underestimate sorry overestimate how
good it is to have your opponents have
doubled pawns in fact i tell this story
often
when i was growing up in the san
francisco mechanics institute chess club
there was a guy named arthur was about
1700 he was a good club player
arthur had a literal phobia of doubled
pawns he would
he would take you know the most insane
measures to avoid having a pair of
double puzzle double pawns can be good
look at this you open up the b file for
him good point you allow him to have a
pawn chain
and okay the pawns are ugly you're not
gonna invite these pawns to prom
but that's fine right because they do
other other stuff
okay bishop e6 what should he have done
to make sure that this standoff
is not going to just kill him here this
is a very typical move
and if you guys are paying attention to
my demonstration of defended and
undefended pieces on chessbase
you can connect the dots here bishop e3
is exactly right
now queen e2 is fine but then the bishop
is only a type 2.
bishop b3 and look at how secure this
bishop is you're never going to have to
worry about losing it
that's what white should have done
knight g5 knight takes c3
now if he takes on d1 and that's
probably what he missed
boom boom and we're up two pawns in the
end game
yeah so e6 and c6 are both possible
e6 creates some weaknesses so between
those two moves i actually think c6
might be the main move
okay why not bishop takes knight there
where
i'm not sure where you meet where where
are you referring to anyways
he goes castles uh pawn to p3 would be
fine
uh except it would it would but but you
would hang the knight right you would
create another undefended piece
make sure that when you're trying to
solve a problem in chess make sure that
you're not creating another one in its
place
very typical cause of blunders if you're
troubleshooting you're like okay there's
one thing i need to solve here
make sure that you're not tunnel
visioning right
a words that are in charlie's nightmares
tunnel visioning is when you
zero in too much on one particular
concept forgetting
about others so
castles brook takes d4 bishop f7 kings
now here
he should have gone bishop b3 and
you guys can see that this knight is
trapped now when your piece is trapped
you shouldn't panic
what you should try to do is figure out
whether you can give that piece up
for the maximum amount of material so
what does that mean there's two possible
moves
knight c3 knight b2 now knight p2 helps
him develop we don't want to help our
opponent develop
so knight takes c3 is the move bishop
takes c5 birch thank you for the sub
phd you see always logical
so here it looks scary but there's
nothing if he goes bishop e6 by the way
it looks like the rook is trapped
but now we have this square and we
skewer the bishops so
here knight c6 not nothing automatic no
knee-jerk reactions developing the
knight
and now the smoke clears we trade the
rooks we infiltrate to the second rank
and we win the game
why not rook d7 instead of rook c8 um
why not rook d7 instead of rook c8
oh yeah rook t7 was possible but i was a
little bit concerned
about leaving that back rank unattended
although i don't think he actually has
anything this would have been possible
so something like this was what
concerned me and then he can play the
move e6 with
tempo also i thought maybe i'd leave the
d7 square available for them why did he
resign
because he's down a piece in an end game
which is quite an overwhelming advantage
at this level